hello and welcome to another gamespot
news update where today we're talking
about the cancellation of the
controversial augment your pre-order
incentive for the new deus ex game
Square Enix have decided to scrap the
Deus Ex mankind divided augmented
pre-orders program admitting that it
received a resounding amount of negative
feedback and saying on Twitter you asked
for this the publisher said initially
wanted to give customers more choice
with the scheme which offered multiple
tiers of rewards depending on how many
people pre-ordered the game first
certain number of global pre-orders the
publisher would give away various DLC
ranging from endgame costume to
soundtracks two extra in-game missions
at the highest tier the publisher would
have released a game four days early
when it was first conceived we wanted
the program to give you more choice
about what you received in terms of
pre-order incentives Square Enix
explained in the past when we chose
those packages ourselves and split them
across regions it has caused frustration
we quickly notice that this new approach
created even more frustration resulting
in a resounding amount of negative
feedback according to the statement all
of the incentive content will be
available to anyone who pre-orders Deus
Ex mankind divided or purchases as day
one edition of the game the publisher
also stated that the release date would
no longer be changed in accordance with
pre-order numbers and that everyone will
gain access to the game on februari 23rd
2016 did you preorder Deus Ex mankind
divided are you satisfied with square
enix's decisions let us know in the
comments below I'm cake you can follow
me on Twitter how not to draw and as
always keep it gangsta calm for all your
news update